all right welcome back everybody it's a
pleasure to have maggie wang from uh
princeton
uh
giving a token policy gradient
magdi take it away
hi can you hear me yeah
okay
um okay so i have 40 minutes
yeah sounds about right
cool
um okay so we're going to talk about
policy gradient
and
so this is a series of
work jointly with many
uh very nice collaborators
so okay so so we all know about policy
gradient right so
in reinforcement learning
sometimes we prefer policy based method
because maybe
it could be easier
to
do optimization over a policy parameter
space
okay
and if we want to use policy-based
method and if we want to use gradient
optimization
so
a one fundamental result is the policy
gradient theorem by saturn
which basically says that if i want to
evaluate the gradient of a value
function with respect to its policy
parameter
then this gradient
can be written in the form of an
expectation
of
cumulative sum
over a sample trajectory generated under
this exact policy pi zeta
[Music]
um so um
in the recent couple of years i think
the community has gained much deeper
understanding into policy ingredient
so there are a number of important
questions to ask
and some of them are partially being
answered but there are still open
questions that we hope to be able to
answer further
so the first question is how do we
estimate policy credit
so um
because one if we want to use policy
ingredient
and keep updating the policy
so what happened what will happen is
we are going to generate
a large number of batches or episodes
by using different policies
but however if we want to estimate the
policy ingredient of a new policy
and then we are going to be entering the
problem which is of policy learning
and when we have off policy data
then the distribution shifts
from older policies to the newer one so
this distribution shift becomes
substantial
and the distribution shift also relates
to how we actually make the updates do
we do balance reduction where what
learning we're choosing
and there's going to be large bias and
even variance
so in practice
so it turns out that the most commonly
used method is still important sampling
which means that for older trajectories
we are going to assign
accumulative product of weights
in order
to do important sampling and the dung
way older tradition
but however whenever we do important
sampling the most naive approach is
going to generate exponentially large
variants
so there are smarter ways to do that but
again important sampling requires
dealing with distributions in a way to
calculate importance weights which is
theoretically
both
theoretically
unstable and practically it means that
usually we have to be able to
pick the window for important sampling
and also calculate weights carefully if
we want to be able to get something more
accurate
okay so further so um we we wish to be
able to leverage function approximation
for policy gradient estimation
so because like there are tons of
value-based methods for approximating
value functions for approximating q
functions
right so one naturally asks is it
possible to learn the gradient of q
in a way that's similar to
learning the q function itself can we
actually use the idea of value function
approximation for estimating policy
gradient
and thirdly the radical question would
be that say that i only care about
estimating a single policy gradient
and maybe this positive gradient is
going to tell a physician which
direction to improve his treatment plan
okay and
we have a lot of our policy data
generated by different physicians
and then statistically speaking what is
the optimal estimator of a single policy
gradient
and how to characterize the estimation
error
okay so that's the problem of estimation
and say that we have powerless
ingredient or a very good estimator for
policy gradient
so the next question is okay we want to
use policy gradient
for optimization
and the the first issue is going to be
that policy organization has
a very complicated and highly non-linear
non-complex landscape
so recently there have been very
insightful works trying to analyze
global convergence of policy gradient
when the policy is either tabular
or soft max
so we do understand that for particular
tabular softmax policies although
without convexity
one can actually have global convergence
to the optimal solution but more
generally than this
there's really not much one can say
about global convergence
okay so beyond the landscape
so say that okay we want to be able to
estimate policy agreement while
updating
the policies
and we want to find an optimal policy
so can we combine a better pg estimate
with a smarter algorithm
and what is the best sample efficiency
we can get
for policy optimization
and even more generally so in this talk
we hope to be able to
extend
the scope of policy gradient measures to
solve problems actually beyond standard
reinforcement learning problems
okay
so firstly policy gradient actually has
its own bellman equation
so
uh the policy gradient bowman equation
can be
uh
can be proved fairly straightforwardly
by
just differentiating both sides
of
the q function by my equation with
respect to the policy parameter
okay
so that basically means that if we know
the q function at stage h plus 1 and
this gradient at stage is h plus one
and then
they should be able to give us
the gradient of qh
with respect to theta
so having this bellman equation is
important because we do know that q
learning and many value-based algorithms
are based on bellman equation so if
policy gradient has its own bellman
equation
that means that we may be able to
learn policy gradient functions in a way
similar to
learning q functions
okay
so
we propose
a double fitted iteration for estimating
policy gradient
which is basically in the same spirit
with fitted q iteration and fitted q
evaluation
so what happens is
as long as we are given a function class
and we may have a batch data if they can
be generated either unpolished or off
policy okay then we can always do
iterative regression to try to fit
the q function and
the q gradient function
together
recursively by minimizing
least square error
over the function class
okay so this is actually a fairly
straightforward approach if you if you
know fitted it fitted q or fitted q
evaluation well enough
you will know that
this is going to be a fairly easy to
implement approach because we only need
to do regression and we on we can easily
use any neural architecture
and this algorithm
actually is very simple conceptually
so doing fitted q iteration repeated q
evaluation will fit it pg iteration so
they are both equivalent to a
model-based plug-in as meter
so plug-in estimator means that whenever
we have a batch data if we try to
project the transitions
in the batch data to our function class
then essentially we're getting an
approximate transition operator which is
an estimate of the transition model of
mdp
so q hat
and gradient q hat are actually all
model based estimators so they are
equivalent to that we estimate the model
first and then plug in the estimated
model transition operator to compute the
corresponding policy gradient and
corresponding q
and another interesting insight here is
that
in the
simple case of linear mdp
the policy gradient estimated by this
algorithm is actually exactly the same
with we first estimate
the q function we get a q hat and then
we try to differentiate the estimated q
function with respect to theta
so this may be actually something people
want to do practice because in practice
we often approximate q functions very
well but however even if we can
approximate q functions
numerically it's challenging or even
intractable to differentiate this
approximate q function with respect to
another policy parameter but this
algorithm says that if we do this fitted
iteration
the outcome of estimator is equivalent
to estimating q and differentiated
okay
so we try to analyze the zero error
bonds for this
policy gradient estimator
notice that our data can be very easily
off policy and there could be
significant distribution shift so we're
able to show that the estimation error
has a finite high probability error
bound which is largely dominated by a
coherence term which we call lambda
theta
so this covariance matrix is too big so
i i didn't include it in the slides
and one can uh we also provide a
companion crammer real lower bound which
actually says that this particular
variance aware upper bound is
statistically optimal
meaning that the fitted iteration gives
the best possible
policy estimator
even in the off policy training case
so
it should be the estimator with the
smallest error bound and variance
so further
there's a very
very intricate insight here
if we try to really uh delve into delve
deeper into the estimation error bound
analysis so because we are right now
we're using functional approximation to
approximate q function and q gradient
function right and also we're dealing
with off policy data we don't we do know
that our policy data creates a
distribution shift and distribution
shift sometimes can jeopardize the
entire estimation
problem and generate and the leads to
significant substantial estimation error
but on the other hand we are also using
function approximation
we are approximating q function
and its gradient function so function
approximation is supposed to be able to
improve generatibility and improve
prediction accuracy
okay so we try to refine the error bound
and to get a reward free version of the
error bond okay
so one can show that the policy gradient
estimation error
is actually bounded by a very
interesting term here
so it is the square root
of a particular divergence function
between
the batch data distribution and the
target policies often measure
okay
so that particular divergence which we
call it
the f restricted chi-square divergence
it turns out to be
the single
important
quantity here to characterize the
hardness and statistical complexity of
policy estimation
okay so this is
a divergence function defined in a
variational dual form
okay
and
it depends on the function approximator
class we are using
so basically we're trying to take soup
over functions in the function class
and we're taking
supremum of this term that measures
some sort of chi-square divergence
between two distributions
but however because this divergence is
defined by taking soup over a function
class rather than taking soup over the
entire l infinity ball
okay so this divergence can be actually
very small if the function class
can annihilate distribution shift
so in other words the fundamental still
error of our policy estimation is
determined by how distribution shift
and our function class are coupled
together
and
the function class restricted chi-square
divergence can be substantially much
smaller than the non-restricted plain
vanilla chi diver chi-square divergence
between the two opposite measures
and even without function approximation
the chi-square divergence is going to be
substantially smaller than the
l-infinite norm between the density
ratio
and
in most
existing works on analyzing distribution
shift and sample efficiency
static error is usually characterized by
l infinity norm of the density ratio
which is only finite when the two
probability density functions are
extremely close to each other
but this theory says that
actually even if the two opposite
measures are very different the
distribution shift can be arbitrarily
large but as long as the relative
distribution shift in the function class
is small
one can get good estimate
and we can further show that this error
bound is min max optimal
okay so that's the the story for
optimal estimation of policy gradient
by using function class
okay
and then uh next
we we aim to study
a problem class which is broader than
classical markov decision process
okay
so in classical markov decision process
we all know that mdp by definition
we're dealing with
additive rewards our objective function
is expectation of sum of rewards so we
take this by granted
and because we worry about sum of
rewards then we can define value
function of state
which is expectation of
sum of rewards
and because we have such definitional
value function then one can show bellman
equation which says that
value of current states can be
decomposed into sum of immediate return
and sum of future value
and further because of this additivity
one can show the policy grid the
classical policy gradient theorem
so we take the value function the
bellman equation the policy gradient
theorem o
for granted
but however
additivity of rewards is actually a
pretty strong assumption
and in many applications that we care
about
we might actually look for searching we
might
actually search for policies
to maximize non-additive rewards
okay so let me give you uh a number uh
several examples
okay
again we can work with markov decision
process but
let's change let's consider more general
objective functions
so one example is if we want to do
exploration
in
a brand new environment so we care about
maybe visiting every possible state
but however
it's hard to model it's very hard to
model this objective as a cumulative sum
of rewards
for example if we try to augment the
state space by memorizing all the states
that have been visited
then we can
make the reward additive however this
augmentation is going to make the state
space exponentially larger than the
original state space
okay
and secondly we might want to be dealing
with safety concerned applications and
also risk-averse applications
we do know that expectations and sums
are risk neutral but what if we care
about a more general coherent risk
function
and thirdly sometimes we want to do
imitation learning so we might have some
known data set either some existing
players
existing players experience or we might
have some summary statistics or marginal
state distribution observations about
other players and when we train our own
policy we want to regularize our policy
using the
data or the known distribution we have
to do some work to do some sort of
imitation in order to treat faster
so all of these different objectives
they are pretty natural and common but
they are not sum of rewards
okay
so this
this new objectives they actually fit
into
a slightly broader mathematical
framework
so we consider here reinforcement
learning for general utility functions
so say that okay we're still trying to
maximize our powers maximize to find the
best policy pi theta
and we care about its utility function
we call it r some argutic function of
the policy
and we see that this utility function is
going to be a functional
of the state action organization measure
generated by this policy
so we want to directly optimize a policy
to
figure out a preferred long-term state
action distribution rather rather than a
single sum of rewards
okay
and we're going to consider concave
function f
which operates over
the policies occupancy measure
okay
note here that because we are no longer
dealing with attitude rewards there are
many things that we took for granted in
classical mdp theory no longer holds so
here we have to prove again that for
this more general convex
markov decision problem
it's actually okay
to only
explore over stationary policies cyclic
and non-stationary policy is not going
to make our objective function bigger
okay
so the prior examples actually all fall
into this category for general td
functions
so first
in standard reinforcement learning we
deal we deal with cumulative reward
so the value function of accumulating
reward is exactly the inner product
between the opposite measure lambda and
the reward function
so basically the functional f is linear
for standard mdp
and even if we want to do exploration
we can simply pick the f function to be
the entropy
of the state
visitation distribution
which is again concave in lambda
so
in the case when we have
state feature map
and we may care about exploration in
order to generate well-conditioned data
and cover the feature space
in this case a natural objective would
be to maximize the smallest angle value
of the state features covariance
and again this objective is a concave
function
of the full state action always measure
and the last example of imitation
for example if
we know the marginal state distribution
generated by some
adversarial player but we don't get to
observe his moves
okay
so we can still try to regularize
our policy to make our policies state
distribution to be close to the expert's
state distribution by using a negative
divergence queue back labor or any other
reasonable divergence function and again
this is a concave utility function
okay
so now what's what's really interesting
here is that if we return to the very
basic of
a mark of mdp and reinforcement learning
theory
we quickly realized that
almost the entire theory of markov
design process relies on the fact that
we are working with cumulative rewards
so if we consider a more general
rotating function to maximize
we no longer have additive rewards
so the consequences are that first we no
longer have value function
because value is sum of rewards now we
don't have additivity
and also we no longer have q functions
they just don't exist
and then because we don't have value we
don't have q then dynamic programming
and bell my equation they all
no longer hold
okay
so uh so basically we have to give up on
value-based algorithms
so
finally let's return to policy
optimization
so since we don't have value-based
algorithms can we still directly
optimize over the policy space
or can we still directly search for the
optimal parameter in the policy
parameters space
and can we still have
algorithms that can be easily
implemented
okay
see
i think i'm going to skip this slide
since we're running out of time
okay
so uh in order to still be able to do
policy gradient or policy optimization
so the first step is we need to be able
to evaluate the policy ingredient
for this bigger
this more general problem
and we can imagine that policy gradient
theorem
doesn't hold anymore because positive
gradient theorem is proved with reward
additivity
okay
so in the positive gradient theorem
first we no longer have this q function
and secondly
this entire expectation of some
structure no longer holds
so we have to be able to
evaluate or compute policy gradient for
this more general problem in a different
way
okay so now let's work with our
generality function r of pi theta and we
want to find this gradient with respect
to policy parameters theta
so the utility is a composition between
the
function f
and the mapping from policy to optimism
measure
so when i say that okay let's just use
the chain rule
but because
inside the composition we have an entire
state action distribution so if we want
to use the chain rule then we have to be
able to estimate
the entire state action opposite measure
and we also need to be able to estimate
the gradient of the distribution with
respect to theta
and we all know density estimation is
a problem that is hardly tractable
and estimating as gradient is even
harder
we don't want to
solve a simpler problem by first solving
an even harder one because the policy
gradient itself could have much smaller
dimensions than the state action always
measure right we are doing primarization
okay
so it turns out that if we return to the
fundamental optimization structure of
markov decision process
one can show that the policy gradient
for this much more generality function
is equivalent to the solution of a min
max optimization problem
so
the trick here is actually very simple
because we are dealing with
because we are dealing with a non-linear
concave utility app
we can simply you
go to its ventral dual
and we are going to introduce a dual
variable which can be viewed as the
shadow reward function we no longer have
word but in the dual form we have
a shadow reward which is the dual
variable
so
and
if
we know
we have the perfect dual variable
which is actually going to be the
cutting plane which is going to come
from the cutting plane of the
alternative function with respect to the
state action opposite measure so if we
have that then we can
we are going to know the policy gradient
immediately
and if we don't have the shadow reward
then one can try to solve the min max
optimization problem
okay so this is not an algorithm yet
but at least we can we can we have a
formula
to
write down what the policy ingredient is
when we
no longer have cumulative sum as our
objective
okay
so now can we estimate
the variation of policy gradient by
solving the min max optimization problem
because the min max optimization problem
looks like a high dimensional problem
right that doesn't make sense to solve
this high-dimensional problem
so it turns out that we can solve it by
just using multi-color sampling so for
example a very
straightforward plug-in approach would
be to just generate on policy sample
trajectories and then we can
approximate unknown functions and
quantity in the min max optimization
problem by taking by taking sample
average over the trajectories
and
then we have
a stochastic min-max optimization
problem which is going to give me an
estimator
of the policy gradient for general td
function
okay
and
in order to solve this problem one can
use any kind of for example stochastic
premodule gradient or accelerates the
quasi-promoted ingredient so this is
actually a problem that has many
tractable solutions
to solve
okay
and i think a more important question is
say that we do this multicultural
sampling and we try to
solve for a stochastic saddle point is
the solution really going to be useful
because the minimization problem has
high dimensional functions involved
and we definitely don't want to
introduce high dimensional noise because
fundamentally we're trying to only get a
single gradient
okay
so it turns out that in theory one can
provide
estimation error bound for
estimating the policy gradient via
stochastic satellite problem and
estimation error is only determined by
smoothness
of
the objective function rather than
underlying dimension of state-space
action space or the probability density
functions
and the proof is based on analyzing the
stochastic stability of settle points
when objective functions are perturbed
with additive errors
okay
so the short story is
yes indeed when we no longer have value
function or bellman equation we actually
can still be able to write down the
formula for policy gradient and we can
actually still be able to estimate the
policy gradient by stochastic minimax
optimization and one can improve
statistical error bonds that are
polynomial and tractable
okay
so now we have figured out how to
estimate a single policy gradient
and now we want to return to the entire
optimization problem
recall that in policy organization so my
policy prioritization can be a neural
net
and the mapping from policy to state
audience measure and then to the general
tdp so there's no known structure it can
be an arbitrary non-complex mapping
so the problem itself
is definitely highly non-complex
okay
and this non-complexity
holds for both standard mdp
and the mvp with general td function
okay
however
if
we try to dig into the landscape
of markov decision process
we do know that
the problem we have in mind maximize
some locative function over positive
space this one is non-complex
but however this problem
is equivalent to another optimization
problem in the space of opposite
measured lambdas
so in the space of
always a major lambdas the optimization
problem is to maximize a concave utility
of lambda
and ob and the constraint is that lambda
has to be some opposite measure
corresponding to a stationary policy
so this constraint
is actually the intersection between a
big linear system
and
the non-negative simplex
so the constraint in the space of lambda
is actually a polyhedral
which means that
the problem if we view it as a problem
in our optimization problem in
distribution it's a very nice convex
optimization problem
okay and if we exploit this
structure
and under
proper assumptions for example if we
have a one-to-one mapping between our
policy parameter space and the space of
lambda
or
if my pronunciation of policy is
sufficiently expressive so that the
problem can be still mapped
mapped to the nice convex operation
problem where lambda belongs to a
polyhedron
okay as long as my policy proposition
doesn't
change this particular hidden convective
structure then we can actually show that
as long as we can find a stationary
solution
in the policy parameter theta space
that solution is going to be globally
optimal
for the entire policy operation problem
okay
and based on this hidden complexity one
can actually further analyze equation
convergence and equation complexity of
policy gradient ascent
okay
so let's say that we don't have any
estimation error we
we have
some oracle that gives me exact policy
gradient at each theta so we just run
grid and ascent
and then we can show that
in general
this algorithm actually converges at a
rate of 1 over t with t being the number
of equations
and in addition if in my objective
function we have for example some quebec
labor divergence which is strongly
convex
what can actually make the algorithm
convert faster or even exponentially
okay
so the analysis is actually uh i think
the conceptually very easy so analysis
is although we although our algorithm
works in the theta space
but when we try to analyze the
convergence and the reduction of
optimality gaps we are going to
translate
the converged analysis to the lambda
space
so although in the syntax space the
convergence and updates may look
wiggly
but however the gradient flow is very
nice and simple in the lambda space
so one can actually analyze convergence
of policy gradient method as if we are
analyzing
with convexity
okay
and again if we uh go back to the
standard
problem when we have cumulative reward
the problem in the lambda space is a
linear program
and all the assumptions naturally hold
with tabular mdp and also actually also
with a soft max
under a little bit of modification
and in this case the intuition
complexity of policy gradient is
actually going to be of order one over
absolute and that's actually much better
than
the one over absolute square equation
complexity that used to be known
okay
and finally so we want to put together
estimation and convergence
so uh there is a particular algorithm
which is too long to
be to show in the slide but there's an
algorithm that combines estimation of
convergence which is really just a
gradient ascent algorithm but it uses a
more accurate estimator for policy
gradient
okay and i want to show that
solving
the markov design process with add with
both cumulative rewards and general
activity the sample complexity is one
over epsilon square
so this sum of capacity is not
surprising because we do know that in
tabular mdp in linear mdp when we use
other methods when we use other value
based methods the sample complexity is
one over epsilon square that's pretty
much exact that's very much expected
but however in the
in policy gradient convergence analysis
the best sample complexity one
have ever got before was one over
epsilon to the power of three
so which means that there used to be
this big gap between
sharp
theory for mdp and
theory for policy gradient sample
complexity and we're finally closing
this gap
and also what's interesting is if we try
to compare those convergence results and
sample efficiency results with convex
optimization so one can conclude that
actually both
iteration complexity and sample
complexity for solving this general tdrl
problem is actually comparable to
stochastic convex authentication
which means that the problem
is actually
from an optimization perspective is
actually not harder not as hard as
we might have expected
okay
so this is the last slide and the
summary of the talk so first we consider
how to get min max optimal estimation of
a single policy gradient and we show
that policy gradient has its own bellman
equation which means that we can
actually do functional approximation and
function fitting to estimate policy
gradient in a way that is very similar
to estimating value functions and q
functions
and
along this line we can provide
statistically optimal error bound for
policy grid and estimate
and error bound is determined by a
particular
that
divergence quantity
that describes how distribution shift
affects how distribution shift is
coupled together with the function class
so
the better function class we use
definitely we have
smaller error even if we could have very
big distribution shift in the original
state action space
and then if we consider
solving policy orientation problems for
objectives that are beyond cumulative
rewards
although we no longer have value in
belmont equation one can still be able
to
estimate policy gradient by solving a
stochastic satellite problem
with statistical guarantees
and finally the entire landscape of
policy of transition
can correspond to a hidden convex
organizational problem in the space of
augustine measures
and if we do the analysis in the correct
space one can actually show that the
equation complexity is a skill that's
one over absolute comparable to convex
of transition and the sample complexity
is one over square one over epsilon
square which finally matches the known
lower bound for
mdp theory
okay so that's the end of my talk thank
you
thank you
any questions from andy
yeah very insightful talk actually so i
was curious about this variation of
policy grading where you showed that
stochastic me max optimization can you
go back to the slide i was wondering
like in the special case where you have
this additive reward setting what is the
interpretation of that mi max
reformulation
oh in the additive reward we just don't
have to do variable let me find it yeah
a good question yeah in the so uh
because we don't have attribute work
we're actually having another inner
minimization over a do variable which is
like a surrogate to that reward but when
we don't have it
then
it's really just a simpler optimization
problem
i see so there is not like any reduction
to what's known
in because there because there you have
like there is a way to compute the
policy gradient there
it does reduce to the known policy
gradient theorem but it requires a
little bit of convex analysis
because uh in the in the typical case
the the the conjugate of linear f so
there will be so we need to be we need
to be we need to do some analysis to to
show that
okay interesting and then for the
stochastic uh stability there you
mentioned that the one over and sample
complexity or the one over and bound
uh only depends on the smoothness right
the smoothness parameter depends on the
state action
size or is no the smoothness is
determined by the objective function and
it is basically determined by the
optimization problem
yeah for example like if we if we i
think um for example it can depend on
the l infinity norm
of
the gradient of the objective function
but if the objective function is linear
the infinite norm of exquisite is really
the l infinity norm of the reward which
is usually considered as one in
classical mdp
i see interesting because there's no
dependence on the state action at all
okay no
yeah thanks a lot thank you
i have a question about uh
when you took the fanshawe duel in the
previous slide i think uh yeah the same
the same the same slide that uh nia
asked you about
actually could you explain like uh
so what is v exactly and like uh
yeah so what is this v function
oh this v function is going to be the
value function
of the value function
using policy
c pi zeta when the reward is given by z
oh i see so that is a sort of like
hallucinated value function
yeah it can be sound like yeah
yes yes it's pretty much like where
we're we're like sort of like doing
coveting pulling optimization so
whenever we have a shadow reward the
cutting plane becomes a linear problem
which gives me actually a value
function corresponding to the gradient
or the corresponding shadow reward
thank you
uh so you mentioned that there's no uh
you know value function when when you
have this general concave nonlinear big
f
um but you have you can define like
local value functions where at any given
uh policy you look at the
first order approximation
uh
yes yes you're right yeah that's
actually because that actually the first
order approximation actually corresponds
to the dual variable
okay i'm just gonna ask if there's any
interpretation i guess you can answer
that yeah that that's exactly the
interpretation thank you for asking
all right so thank you again magdie
thank you guys thank you very much
and uh we'll be back for the last talk
in
[Music]
sounds like